okay you might remember this guy named
william barr
he is the attorney general after all
he's donald trump's
hatchet man attorney general and he up
until yesterday
had all but completely disappeared from
the public eye
since he attended that white house super
spreader event
for donald trump supreme court pick amy
coney barrett
that was that event which set in motion
this chain of coronavirus cases
barr went missing for a while after that
point
bar resurfaced yesterday to say without
any hesitation
at this point there is no evidence of
widespread
election fraud that would have affected
the election results in any way
now you still have people saying well
what about this one vote
a dead person really did vote the point
is
there is no evidence at this point of
fraud of any materially significant
nature to the election you also
immediately had counter articles coming
out saying no
barr didn't clear everybody of fraud
what barr
said is to date there is no evidence
of materially significant election fraud
he said this in an interview yesterday
with the associated press
his exact statement was quote to date
to date we have not seen fraud on a
scale
that could have affected a different
outcome in the election
there's been one assertion that would be
systemic fraud
and that would be the claim that
machines were programmed to skew the
election results
and the dhs and doj have looked into
that and so far
we haven't seen anything to substantiate
that
as this was breaking donald trump
tweeting quote
hope everybody's watching oan right now
other media afraid to show
people are coming forward like never
before
large truck carrying hundreds of
thousands
of fraudulent fake ballots to a voting
center
terrible save america so at this point
donald trump's claims are sort of a
running parallel commentary that's
completely divorced from all the facts
on the ground
and then immediately after william barr
said this there was speculation that
donald trump was going to fire him
because within moments of that
interview being published a william barr
was seen arriving at the white house
and the speculation was oh boy trump
called him in and he's going to fire him
right now
that's not at all what was going on that
was a pre-planned meeting
with the chief of staff mark meadows
cnn's caitlyn collins reporting that
quote
attorney general barr is in the west
wing
for a meeting with mark meadows an
official says
the meeting was planned before his
interview with the associated press
now it certainly wouldn't be beyond
trump
to fire william barr for saying this
that would actually be totally
unsurprising
but the speculation that the timing of
barr going to the white house
after saying yesterday no evidence of
election fraud
um that was mere speculation and he was
actually there to meet with the chief of
staff mark meadows
now there are all sorts of other things
going on involving the justice
department
some not very good for trump which could
have been the reasons
for william barr or at least the subject
matter of william barr's meeting with
chief of staff mark meadows let's talk
about one of those
next one of our sponsors today is a
brand called
so keto-licious if you follow a
ketogenic diet or you just want to cut
back on carbs
check this out so keto-licious is
perfected ketogenic crusts for baking
your favorite foods
they make a delicious keto dessert crust
which comes in a chocolate and vanilla
flavor
and is perfect for making things like
pies they also offer a premium
keto pizza crust which i myself have
been using at home
to make pizzas and it's absolutely great
it's ready to go
right out of the freezer when you cook
it it doesn't fall apart like some of
these other low carb
crusts do it's high fat which is perfect
for keto
it's grain free and gluten free they
don't use any soy or
additives preservatives or fillers but
most importantly
it just tastes good i can tell you first
hand eating a low carb diet
does not mean you have to sacrifice your
favorite things like
pizza and pies and so keto-licious
makes it really easy and really
delicious just go to davidpakman.com
pizza the link is right underneath this
video they will give you 10
off your entire order when you use the
coupon code pacman